Denzel Washington is one of Hollywood's
highest-grossing actors he's won two
Oscars in two Golden Globes and last
year he received the Cecil D DeMille
Lifetime Achievement Award Washington
directed in stars in his latest film
fences it's expected to have a
successful night at the Academy Awards
here's a look at his incredible career
so far
listen up I'm coach Boone I'm gonna tell
you all about how much fun you're gonna
have this season Denzel Washington and
his ability to be both versatile and
familiar has made him one of Hollywood's
most sought-after stars we are in a die
we have lost vertical control for more
than three decades he's been bringing
iconic men to life like civil rights
leader Malcolm X we didn't land on
Plymouth Rock Plymouth Rock landed on us
and wrongfully convicted boxer Rubin
Carter in the hurricane he won a Golden
Globe for that one I've been locked up
for 30 years
Denzel earned his first Golden Globe an
Oscar for his portrayal of private trip
a former slave turned Union Army soldier
in the 1989 film glory a much' matter
what happened to mom
we Manning his many roles as a good guy
have endeared him to audiences and
critics but Denzel who once said the bad
guys have all the fun has played his
share of those two I'm the man up in his
face as a corrupt cop in training day
which earned him his second Oscar King
Kong ain't got on me an American
gangster Frank Lucas where's my money
red top gave you the package he's broken
handing me mom
ha will become his latest project the
film adaptation of August Wilson's
Pulitzer prize-winning play fences is
being lauded by critics and moviegoers
as long as you in my house you put a
seal on the end of it when you talk to
me yes sir you eat everyday
yes sir got a roof over your head yes
sir got clothes on your back yes sir why
you think that is cuz of you well I know
it's cuz of me but why do you think that
is cause you like me yes
Denzel Washington yes Denzel yes won a
Tony Award for Best Actor the 2010
Broadway revival offenses and we are so
glad that you were here thank you so
much for joining us at the table having
but I wish the audience could see cuz
part of the fun don't you think I was
watching you watch the clip and reciting
the line what's it like for you when you
look at your life like that I don't you
don't know I don't know I don't sit at
home and watch I'm sure you don't but
listen you've had such a career when you
went let's talk about fences cuz I saw
you in Broadway on the stage I saw you
on the movie of course so I'm thinking
either you're like Troy you like the
story you like August Wilson you like
all of the above I love all this Wilson
yeah me and and I love the opportunity
to do the play and to to act with great
actors Stephen Henderson and Illya and
miss Davis yes
Viola Davis yes and Michael Dean Russell
wanna be me but but what about this
particular character and this particular
body of work with August Wilson cuz
you're a director too hmm in this
particular well I mean answers you know
he wrote a masterpiece yeah and he's one
of the I think top five you know with
Tennessee Williams Arthur Miller Eugene
O'Neill Edward Albee August Wilson were
you worried about that since it's so
iconic about doing it pulling it off
yeah well because we had done the play
and we'd had success with the play
kinda so I knew we could do it it's a
challenge yes it was a motivating factor
the motivator because it's not easy no
you know no every morning after about
two and a half hours sleep I pop up
panicking about the shots I didn't get
and then you immediately start working
on the next day what did you see in Troy
that reminded you of people in your own
family your own father
um my father was nothing like Troy other
than he was working class he was a real
gentleman and my father wasn't a yellow
or scream anything like that not not
highly educated made some of the same
suggestions to me like you know get a
good trade and you know he told me he
could he work for the Department of
Water and Power whatever they called it
in New York and he talked to me about
getting me a job there in 25 years I
could be a supervisor that wouldn't if
we live to see you become the story you
became mmm I remember going to I was he
passed away in Virginia I remember being
down there and going in a store and he
was saying to people you know who that
is you know and they didn't you know
yeah that's my son that's coming I'm
Denzel Washington jr. yeah so for him
that was was a big deal and you and
Viola Davis together on screen on stage
there is there does seem to be a special
kind of chemistry between the two of you
am i reading are we reading it right
he's just one of the great actors of all
time
yeah now happens to be her time yeah I
knew I'd not say I've known it but many
of us have known it for years and now
the bigger audiences are getting to
witness her brilliance it was so great
to see her win the Golden Globe and she
thanked you specifically and she also
mentioned for telling anybody on the set
every day to remember the love huh what
do you mean by that because especially
for the actors who had done the play
will do the we had done it together I
didn't want everybody to start where we
finished if you don't care about their
relationship to begin with or if you
don't believe they really love each
other then the the betrayal of meaning
is do you have something to say to Biola
because it happened to you with Sydney
didn't what do you mean you Sydney gave
you good advice oh yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah he'll do to give her good vice yeah
still does I mean what are you gonna
tell well would be better yeah
well what did Sydney tell ya what he
told me was the first four or five films
you make will determine how you're
perceived in this business
Wow mm-hmm so he didn't tell me what not
to do there was a role I was up for that
which I wasn't crazy about so he didn't
say don't do that role but he did say
what he said just remember just remember
I thought yeah yeah I didn't have to say
that everybody all right
you know but because though you're
pretty good at advice I'll never forget
an interview that I read with you you
actually did it with Oprah Magazine
which is why I remember when you were
talking about your kids you've got four
kids and you said you tell them do what
you've got to do so that you can do what
you want to do yes I love that I walked
out of there and said that to my kids
what does that mean to you and how has
it played out in your life do what you
got to do so you can do what you want on
it because it's not the other way around
I was just talking about my work that
day yes I remember yeah they want to go
out and play however you got it you got
to do then you can do what you want to
do and then you and then you're free to
do what you want to do yeah good agree
yeah I know now there's a show on HBO
called ballers huh
there's a guy in it called John David
washing that's correct see your favorite
character he's really Ricky Zinta's
Ricky characters really good he you know
he's making a mark for himself as all of
my children huh yeah and we're proud of
did you want him to get in this business
your wife's in the business too she's an
actress I didn't see it coming did not
but I'm not surprised
and my wife's a movie buff he watches
everything so the kids have grown up
watching movies so they got it honest
they're real movie fans satisfying is
directing for you yeah I love seeing
other people do well that grew up in the
Boys and Girls Club I grew up as a coach
so directing is a natural for me because
I've never been an out front person it's
so interesting how my career and life is
turned out because I've never been that
person I'm more but want to see
everybody else do well just as you know
now I have the opportunity
congratulations we're very very excited
I can't wait for the Oscar night yeah
thank you thank you thank you fences is
playing yeah theaters right now wherever
you like to go see your favorite movie
denim
but grats thank you